hello and thank you for joining us today
my name is kobi magnesi i'm a product
manager for gke
and i have the pleasure to have here
with me today donna von carter
senior devops engineer at dexcom
thanks kobe it's a pleasure to be here
as kobe said my name is donovan carter
i'm a senior devops engineer with dexcom
i've been working with dexcom and the
devops team on our platform team
for the last three years and it's been a
joy and an honor to get to know kobe
uh through our mutual love and interest
of google kubernetes engine which we're
here to talk to you today about
awesome so we are here to share with you
some of the best practices that you can
follow
to achieve high availability and
business continuity with gk
but first let's define what business
continuity means
business continuity means having a
proper plan preparation and mitigation
strategy in place
so in case something happens with the
potential to disrupt your business
your organization will have the ability
to sustain its critical application
we'll break this discussion to two parts
day zero and day two
and for each one we'll provide some key
recommendation
and my context on this is to discuss
what dexcom
how dexcom leverages uh this business
continuity
approach um for those of you may not be
aware dexcom is
a industry leader in the continuous
glucose monitoring space
what that means is for people with type
1 diabetes we give them a platform of
services that they can use to both keep
in touch with
their uh own disease or the disease of a
loved one
as well as as far as monitoring levels
of their actual glucose blood glucose
because of that we have chosen
kubernetes and google kubernetes engine
specifically
because with the needs of our customers
being what they are
we have to provide that service to them
in a highly available
way and so the obvious choice was to go
with google kubernetes engine
so can you share more donovan why you
decided to use a managed service uh
instead of you know using your own
kubernetes and install it on your
your environment absolutely um it comes
from experience
we were using another cloud provider
prior to our migration to google a few
years ago
and on that cloud provider we had made
the decision to
essentially deploy our own kubernetes
service within the cloud
what we found out is that it's really
hard to do that it requires a lot of
operations and we're going to get into
that today
and we decided not to uh not to
invest that toil some of that toil the
monitoring the
alerting all the things that go into
running your own kubernetes which you
can do
because google presented itself as not
only an industry leader and a
contributor to the kubernetes
project but also provides it as a
managed service which to us i mean
the the things that we have to deal with
on a day-to-day was very very attractive
and so far we've been really really
excited about that the other added bonus
is that it scales it scales ridiculously
well
and we don't have to do anything we
don't really have to think about it
it's been a life changer for us to go
from where we were
several years ago to where we are now
and it's exciting to see where we're
going to go in the future
awesome so let's look at several
recommendations we have
for day zero and when thinking about
high availability of gke cluster
it is important to carefully plan the
topology and configuration
of your gk cluster before you even
deploy your workloads
let's look quickly on the gke
architecture and main components
when you provision a new kubernetes
cluster gk provisions the machine the
underlying gca resources
that are required for the control plane
and the nodes
we also manage the rollout of the
kubernetes version and patches
and their availability in the gke fleet
gk manages the control plane
including all the components running on
it things like
api server htd and others we also manage
the software that runs on the nodes that
includes
operating system image cubelet and
others
when you create a cluster you can decide
on the right topology for your business
you can choose to create a zonal cluster
which includes one replica of your
control plane
and then you can decide whether you want
to have all your nodes
span across three different zones or
whether you want to keep them all in one
zone
with the control plane that really
depends on your needs
from the environment the alternative is
to create a regional cluster
for which gk provisions three machines
for the control plane
and the node pools are also span across
three availability zones
the control plane redundancy provides a
high availability
control plane which in turns offer
higher sla for the kubernetes api
even though your business application
those that run on the nodes
will continue to run and serve traffic
when the control plane is down
temporarily for example for maintenance
it is recommended to use regional
cluster for highly available workloads
kubernetes control plane is responsible
to observe
scale and repair your cluster and when
higher availability is required
regional clusters should be preferred
whichever topology you end up using the
geeky offer a fully managed experience
for the control plane that means that we
take care of backups repairing the
control plane if something happened
we make sure it's available through
monitoring health checks
and auto repair we also keep you up to
date and we upgrade your control planes
to the latest kubernetes version and
patch
and security patch available in a
reliable manner and most importantly
you get google google sre to monitor and
manage your infrastructure for you
nodes are shared responsibility that
means that while the control plane is
hosted in a google project
the nodes are run in your project in the
customer project
that being said gk offers a variety of
capabilities that
automate the life cycle management of
the nodes as well
and we'll cover those next so now that
you
decided on the cluster topology it is
important to consider the scaling
strategy
while scalability is important for
continuity scaling is necessary to
ensure that as you grow
we match your needs so we can grow the
number of pods and number of nodes
based on demand gk includes several auto
scaling capabilities that
allow gke to automatically resize your
cluster based on
your configuration and some monitored
signals
um donovan i would i would love to hear
how dexcom is using
scaling auto scaling as well absolutely
dexcom's grown tremendously and and
being a part of it has been an awesome
experience
but part of that comes with you know
design and planning um
and specifically having to scale up
resources and being a part of a cloud
provider
such as google really really helps with
that um things that we don't have to
think about thanks to the gke cluster
auto scaler are
do we have enough nodes for our
workloads thanks to the gke cluster auto
scaler
that problem is solved it brings in new
nodes whenever we need them
additionally we've been able to leverage
horizontal pod auto scaling in concert
with the cluster auto scaler
to provide a better quality of service
to our customers during peak utilization
hours
being a worldwide company that can be at
any time of the day
uh depending on what region we're
looking at so having to have a person
monitor that and manually intervene just
doesn't make sense
uh we've also seen uh the opposite when
our when we're at our valley utilization
period
we're able to save money as well as
resources
for google by scaling down to an
acceptable threshold to provide the same
quality of service
and not use those resources which has
been wonderful
and auto scaling really help you with
scaling up and down
to meet your demand but sometimes we do
need to do some capacity planning
especially
you know when you expect some peak
demand seasons
uh like black fighter cyber monday or
new year
in this period of time we may want to
reserve gce capacity so that when we
need that capacity for example for
scaling repairing or upgrading
we'll have a reserved pool of resources
available for the cluster to consume
basically gk reservation is an
integration between gke
and gce zonal reservation so you can
create a specific or non-specific
reservation and gk will create new
resources based on the pool
reserved for you there's an example here
on the right side
where we create reservation of three
machines
we verify the reservation and then we
create a cluster to consume
any matching reservation that we created
now that we cover the provisioning
and scaling of nodes let's talk about
the application your business
application those that run on the nodes
different applications of different
behavior and needs
some applications are stateless and some
are stateful
more than 50 percent of gke customers
run stateful
workloads on kubernetes successfully
it's not as easy task but luckily
kubernetes ng-key offer configuration
and tools
to support different type of application
donovan do you guys
run any stateful application on gk we do
and when you say it's not easy
you're absolutely right there are
certainly things that uh make it
difficult or or
more less difficult and i think we're
going to get into those
here in just a second exactly and
and when you run different type of
application you also need to think about
disruption and how you can tolerate
disruption
po disruption budget or pdb allows you
to state your disruption
tolerance in other words if your
application is let's say
replicated you can specify how many
replicas
you are willing to sacrifice when
voluntary events
like upgrade happens in this example on
the right side here
we have we specify that we cannot
tolerate less than two replicas of our
application
this is just another way to say max
unavailable equal one
if you have three replicas and you want
only one to be
unavailable gke respects pdb
up to 60 minutes and also termination
grace period up to 60 minutes so that's
two hours in total
as i mentioned pdb covers voluntary
events like upgrades or repair
as you can imagine if there is a failure
of the physical machine for example pdb
clearly won't be able to mitigate that
the other thing you want kubernetes to
know about your workloads
is whether you would benefit from
collocating some of your pods on the
same machine
or maybe actually if you do so if you do
collocate
some of the parts on the same machine
you run into risk
kubernetes scheduler automatically
spreads your pods across
nodes however sometimes for example
let's take you know a stateful
application like redis or zookeeper
a quorum of servers is required to
successfully commit mutation to data
by default kubernetes may decide to
co-locate pods in stateful set
on the same pod however for for business
continuity
we want to make sure that collocated
pods don't present the risk of single
point of failure
right so if we have stateful set we can
use
pod anti-affinity for example to make
sure that kubernetes don't schedule
more replicas on the same machine so
each replica gets its own machine
on the flip side some application may
benefit from actually being collocated
for example let's say you have a web
server and a cache service you want them
to be on the same machine for better
performance
and and low latency donovan are you guys
using
any port under affinity or affinity um
with your application
yeah it's exactly like you said kobe um
we want to make sure our sensitive
workloads aren't exposed to
single points of failure uh stateful
sets specifically
but also we use preemptable nodes and as
you know preemptable nodes only last for
a max of 24 hours
so we want to make sure that our highly
available workloads are truly highly
available and not subject to single
points of failure
and and free bonus content preemptable
nodes are a great way to find out if
your workload is really susceptible to
that or not
right and and before we move to cover
day two there is one
more important aspect of business
continuity and it's about
having accurate signals uh so kubernetes
know exactly how your workload should
behave
and it can actually monitor the the
health and the state of your workloads
the first one is readiness probe uh if
your application for example takes some
time
to start to initiate you don't want
kubernetes to start sending customer
traffic to that workload
until it's fully ready to serve traffic
you do so by setting up the readiness
probe
the other important signal is liveness
is your workload
healthy and live or does it require a
repair
setting this probe can provide better
signal to kubernetes
and also avoid false positive cases in
which kubernetes will try
to repair unnecessarily
so now that we set up the cluster let's
cover several recommendations for
day two so one of the most important
things you need to carefully plan for
day two
is your upgrade strategy and
specifically a plan to continuously
upgrade your cluster that's because
kubernetes minor version
is released roughly every three months
from open source
and a patch version may be released
every month because kubernetes run on
both
the control plane and the nodes there
are basically two places to manage when
it comes to managing
and there are many reasons why it's
crucial to keep your cluster up to date
among others is support right supported
versions are
get regular updates and security patches
um and we often time uh sherry pick
fixes from one supported version to
another
kubernetes release a new minor version
every three months and it supports
up to two minor version back um that
translates to roughly supporting each
minor version for about nine months
one important thing to call out is is
that an open source announced that with
kubernetes 119 um
warranty will be the first release to
officially receive
a year of patch support so effectively
prolonging the support period from
9 months to 12 months for kubernetes
minor version
the other requirement is to maintain
supported version skew
between your control plane and the nodes
nodes cannot run
newer version than the control plane and
they have to be within two minor version
from the control plane so
for example if your control plane runs
on 119 your node pools can run
119 118 or 117 the currently supported
versions
since gk automatically upgrade the
control plane in the fleet
it is recommended to use auto upgrade or
at least
have a plan to manually upgrade nodes on
a regular basis
this way you'll avoid getting into an
unsupported version skew
situation with the upgraded control pin
if you do decide to manage your own
upgrade workflow
you also want to make sure that your
upgrade strategy support any compliance
that your workload may be subject to
there are different compliance pci dss
soc2 and hipaa
that dexcom is following as a medical
devices company each one of these
compliance
has actually specific section that
speaks about how
fast you should consume critical patches
so you definitely want to take a look
into these compliance and make sure that
your upgrade strategy
follow the compliance in gk we offer
fully automated process to upgrade both
control plane and nodes control planes
are managed
and by google and we initiate their
upgrade as part of our gke release
your business application the workloads
running on the node stay up and running
when we upgrade the control plane and
during the control plane upgrade
you are unable to change the cluster
configuration for several minutes
because we are taking the control plane
down while bringing a new one so when we
upgrade zonal control plane
we do it by creating a new control plane
with the new version
then we move the network and the disk
over and delete the old control plane
regional control planes are upgraded in
a similar fashion
but you get the redundancies of three
control planes so you always have two
control planes available
when we upgrade one at a time
node upgrade can be automated as well
and we strongly recommend you to use
auto upgrade
to ensure that your nodes are always
upgraded to match your control plane
version
that approach syncing your control plane
version and your node pool version
not only keeping your in node
infrastructure up to date but it also
mitigate the risk of version skew that
we discussed earlier
by now you may be wondering why wouldn't
i use auto upgrade
it is indeed the recommendation and
while the benefits are
clear you want to ensure business
continuity
also during times of maintenance node
upgrades
used to follow the work the workflow of
delete and then create that means that
when we do upgrade node pools
we delete one of the nodes from the node
pool and then we bring a new one with
the new version
we changed that workflow recently with
search upgrade
we search upgrade we create and then we
delete
in other words we bring a new node with
the new version and only when that node
is ready
then we gracefully drain the old node
you can actually control
how many nodes can be additionally
created for search
and also how many existing nodes you are
willing to sacrifice for the upgrade
process
the combination of max surge and max
unavailable
also allow you to control the pace of
the upgrade and it actually
allows you to accelerate node upgrades
so which which can be
important especially if you have large
cluster
um donovan i know that you guys also
have very large clusters and you are
using search upgrade to benefit
for more efficiency that's absolutely
right kobe and and it's like
you said we we see a great increase in
the continuity of the services because
they have a place to go
and when that node gets uh taken away as
opposed to having no place to go when
the node gets taken away
and also it allows us to do our upgrades
faster
we can bring more nodes online and
remove nodes as we we need to
which greatly reduces i mean you think
about all the places around the world
the companies have to be these days
dexcom
is no different we we certainly have
seen great benefits in terms of the
amount of time it takes to
execute a node pool upgrade thanks to
surge upgrade
we it's great and and you know we spoke
about the importance of upgrades
to ensure business continuity in day two
and also the potential disruption that
these upgrades may bring
to running cluster knowing that
different customers have different
version management
needs we introduced release channels
in gk with the objective to actually
simplify the process of choosing your
upgrade path
and also to allow you to control the
type of upgrades that you need for your
cluster
think about it this way some customers
may want to use the latest
kubernetes version because they have
some dependencies on newer api
or capability or because they have some
specific business objectives
other customers may prefer stability
over everything else
over functionality and the freshness of
a version with release channels and
there are three release channels rapid
regular and stable
you can choose where you want to be in
terms of
upgrade path so instead of choosing a
specific version
you can subscribe your cluster to a
release channel that meets your need
and gke will take care of the upgrade
the differences between
channels are soak time and maturity of
the release
so we first introduced the version to
the rapid channel we let it soak
we promote it to regular we let it soak
again and then eventually we promote it
to stable um don't worry
are you using release channels or the
rapid or the red stable channels
in your production environment i can't
go into specifics on that
uh but i can tell you that uh release
channels have greatly
uh simplified how we evaluate the
upgrade process
um historically we'd have to kind of
pick and choose and
study release notes religiously and now
we get a recommendation from google
saying this has had this amount of soak
time and we've looked at it and believe
it's the right version
for um the workloads that you're looking
at so for us we have
some sensitive workloads we want to make
sure that they're using the stable
release channel
for other workloads or other
environments maybe we use different
release channels that are maybe more
aggressive or have newer features
so that we can do that earlier in our
development cycle and it is important to
mention that
you can unsubscribe a cluster from
release channel if you need to do that
and you can also migrate between release
channels in some cases
so this is all sound great you can
automate the process you can figure
configure the nature of the upgrade and
control the version maturity
however kubernetes upgrade can introduce
breaking changes
and they need to be tested and validated
in a pre-production environment
so that you can ensure business
continuity this is why we are
introducing
available versions for channels each
channel will include
one default version and available
versions
when a version becomes default auto
upgrade triggers the rollout server
to promote the default versions and
upgrade the control plane first and then
your node pulls if you are using auto
upgrade
before versions become default gke will
make it available in the fleet
patch versions will be available one
week before rollout and minor version
which tend to be a little bit more
riskier
will be made available four weeks before
rollout
we recommend testing available versions
on pre-production environment to
mitigate
business continuity risks and also to
ensure that when we do
upgrade your production environment auto
upgrade can be completed
successfully you can use the command
line that i have in the bottom of the
slide
to view the default and available
versions for the release channel that
you are
using for your cluster and
sometimes disruption simply cannot be
tolerate right i mean
there are some peak business seasons or
you know major company events like trade
fair
we recommend to set up exclusion window
for these events with extrusion window
you can specify a range of dates
in which you want us to completely
refrain from any maintenance
you can also set up maintenance windows
to say
when you do prefer maintenance to happen
that can help you
not only improve predictability of the
upgrade but it can be very handy
especially now when people work from
home
you might want to ensure team
availability and alignment with the
working schedule when maintenance
actually takes place
dexcom also have i assume major holidays
and um you know plan peak business hours
um how do you use maintenance and
exclusion windows
yeah it's funny you mentioned you know
working from home and kind of the nature
of the situation that we all find
ourselves in because you know
in the olden days we'd want to see
people you know in the office
to manage things and now with working
from home that looks a little different
but we still want to have people awake
and available and in their office
uh wherever that may be just in case um
because
you want to just be online and ready
you're not waking up no one likes to
wake up in the middle of the night for
things like this
um and and similarly you know when it
comes to holidays or certain events
we find that you know are there times
that we would just not want to risk
an upgrade just to make sure we provide
the best quality of service to our
customers
absolutely having that flexibility has
been critical for us
and will be will continue to be critical
for us as we continue to grow
that's awesome and i think you know
another recommendation that
we already kind of implicitly mentioned
several times
is having multiple environments set up i
can't stress enough
how important and essential it is to
have a pre-production environment in
place
so you can reliably deliver upgrades to
your infrastructure and to your software
safely and in timely manner you can
think about it
in a way that you have testing
environments to test out new releases
before
rolling them out to production in this
case we recommend subscribing both your
testing cluster and your production
cluster to the same channel so you can
that you can use the same version
between testing
and production in some cases you may
want to consider canary
or even second development environment
to test out newer releases
using the rapid channel that will give
you
an opportunity to stay ahead of the
curve by testing out new kubernetes
features
or api and basically improve your time
to market
when those versions get promoted from
rapid to regular
and then finally to stable with multiple
environments
we also need an efficient way to
orchestrate and upgrade workflow across
multiple environments
but in order to be proactive about it
you need to be able to predict when an
upgrade is scheduled for your cluster
there is a great way to do so we have
gke release notes that also offer
rss feeds you can you can use that
also if you are using release channels
each channel offers a separate release
note so you can only subscribe to the
updates that's relevant to your cluster
you can use gke api specifically git
server config
to retrieve the list of available
version
these all options are great but they do
require you
to pull the information on a regular
basis so you need to be proactive about
it
so to simplify this this process even
more we are introducing gke upgrade
notification which will be
better launched later this quarter
upgrade notification is based on cloud
pub sub it allows customers to subscribe
to upgrade events
and get automatically informed about new
available versions
and also when the upgrade actually takes
place on their cluster
in this case that i have here in this
slide we have
a devops team using a slack channel and
unification is being pushed to their
channel to their slack channel
through the pub sub subscription and the
team
this way know about and notified ahead
of time about new
versions this way the team can
optionally orchestrate a specific
workflow for example
upgrade their testing environment first
validate the release make sure that the
release
is ready to be safely roll out into
production environment
so let's put everything together we
spoke about different concepts
a recommended approach to automate and
streamline upgrades
would involve pre-production environment
using the available version that we
mentioned before
and upgrade notification that's set up
on your cluster
that will inform your team when a new
available version
is ready for them to test and certify
and eventually
a production environment subscribe to a
release channel using the default
version
in that channel so we've covered a lot
uh and and if you can believe it we've
actually got more we could cover
um but we hope that you've gotten a
sense of some of the best practices and
recommendations both from a real world
experience as well as from google
and google's experience managing gke to
know enough to be really really
dangerous when it comes to running
a highly available really tough um with
strict slos slas uh product in google
kubernetes engine
um there are a lot of things on the
slide that we could talk at great length
about
uh but we won't for the interest of time
but we also
just wanna thank you real quick for
spending your time with us
and getting to hear a little bit about
this and i really appreciate kobe's time
and getting to do this with them one
because it's just fun
and two because it's something that i
really care about so thank you kobe and
thanks folks watching at home
thank you for tuning in